afin de nous protéger contre une menace quasiment inexistante.
Et pourtant, nous n'investissons presque rien
pour nous protéger contre la menace bien réelle et inévitable
que représentent les épidémies de maladies infectieuses.
Ne vous y trompez pas : la question n'est pas de savoir
« si », mais « quand » cela arrivera.
Ces agents pathogènes vont poursuivre leur évolution
et ils finiront par menacer toute la planète.
Les vaccins sont notre meilleure défense.
Si nous voulons éviter des épidémies telles qu'Ebola, nous devons absolument
prendre des risques et investir dans le développement de nouveaux vaccins
et les produire en quantité suffisante.
Il faut le voir comme une solution de secours :
une solution prête à être utilisée,
tout en priant pour ne jamais en avoir besoin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)